what's going on reject nation we are
almost done with all of us are dead we
are at episode 10 today if you can't
chomp into that like button also major
thanks to all those who have joined us
on our patreon page your support means a
lot full length watch vlogs for all of
us are dead are over there along with a
bunch of other shows and lastly them
boys at prepper thanks for helping us
edit down these highlights let's get to
it people
[Music]
no
don't point that pipe in my mom
stop making noise guys
losing your rain advantage
[Music]
come on dude
at this point
ah
[Laughter]
surrender
come on
no what the [ __ ]
no
oh that's messed up you couldn't
[Music]
oh dang
[Applause]
oh yes finally crossed paths
the hero
now she's so goddamn focused secure the
perimeter then family reunion
she gonna forget what you did nope
oh
it's crawling around out there somewhere
i'm there
you guys ball
god
run away
why
oh ho ho ho
no
[Music]
roundhouse kick all their face
no dude no
oh no
oh my god no
oh oh sacrifice himself
[Applause]
respect all that time dedicated is
saving his ass
maybe he'll come back as a humber
guinea got swarmed
no no
there's two down
you're still alive
not for long
instant karma
oh
i feel fellow bad for you
tan
oh and there it is
unless this guy finds now we got two
down
oh
come on come back
oh wow
she had like sores all over her face
that is not the information that we're
hoping for
yep that's what i was afraid of ugh
um
[Music]
the way to find out if they're actually
infected is just feed them human food
and if they
don't react negatively to it they're
fine it's a good call actually
i think this dude's gonna get turned
into a zombie
pick up some christmas presents along
the way
damn you guys got to get some food
um
[ __ ] feel it
goddamn korean troubles
ha ha
no
[Music]
probably some protective gear in here
too somewhere
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i need more eyeballs
[Laughter]
you guys must have excelled in your arts
and crafts
[Laughter]
i know what the nis is
i would have eaten that [ __ ] in
[Music]
i secret covet still exists in this
world yeah guys you don't have any rapid
antigen tests
[Laughter]
i thought he was last year
we should go low
[Laughter]
you
know i mean you're gonna be fine you
don't need any pads
donate them to the group
[Music]
[Music]
that is some creative ass [ __ ] right
there oh man
god that would be so freaking terrifying
[Music]
throw some balls
one of you has to bait them away
yeah
he's used to it by now he's falling off
way higher things
[Applause]
there it goes
he knew they were focusing he didn't
even get to eat oh he will now
i'll bait them away then man get on that
box
bait them away
[Music]
poor guy
there you go
come on man get some distance
no
oh man that guy really sacrificed it all
yeah
maybe he'll be rewarded as a hamby
oh
man
sorry [ __ ] no
oh just turn
[Music]
my
already
[Applause]
you knew that was coming
oh [ __ ] dang
why would you walk into a building
without a weapon prepared
oh she sees her looking right past her
what is this guy's scent ability
she can open it yeah
god damn it
oh my god
don't get bit holy crap please turn the
[ __ ] around holy crap please turn around
what
for real
oh yeah i guess it's fine
thank god yeah it's going to get bit
right out yeah
don't worry the next episode will start
and then he'll get finished
junior got the short end of the stick
this episode man didn't even get to eat
had a final meal before going right down
death row came up with the plan
well yeah that was a good episode man
it's thrilling i'm glad we finally got
the convergence of the two groups
it's like watching al pacino and robert
de niro finally cross pass and he more
closer to a superhero movie like when
finally these superhero characters get
interact where they're like bickering at
first and they're fighting they're not
getting along before eventually they
gotta work together as a unit
that's more along the lines of what it
was
that was good [ __ ] man
[ __ ] confessing to the archer girl oh
this feeling that's such a good scene i
love the smoker trick that's how i
always identified her is yeah
she's she's so fun she's she's one of my
favorites for sure to come out of this i
like the shades of her character yeah
because like she's so good at putting up
the front
but then in the moments of true
intensity you see beyond that vernier
and i think she's really good at playing
that yeah she's a caring woman yeah very
much so very much so
and even with um chong's son man
yeah watching
how he had to deal with the death of his
mom it must really stop you in your
tracks whenever it's someone you
actually know
i would have to imagine yeah i mean
because there's all that
i feel like no amount of zombie movie
logic will prepare you for when your
time comes to see the relative turn
their head and oh no
but i really like the way they handle
that i like the way he's like in shock
basically throughout that and slowly has
to kind of be brought back into the room
and i mean like it totally makes sense
and yeah it was like really
heartbreaking like this was such an
intense episode
for so many reasons and one of them was
just like emotional intensity just like
so many this is this might have been
like one of the more tear-jerkery
episodes just because of how painful
some of the situations become especially
i didn't cry once oh well you know
it's just because you have a heart of
stone yeah i never cried once during the
show you've never cried in any show i
got a little emotional when you young
died just because he was like saying
let's go home
yeah let's go home well at homegirl like
calling out for a mom like things like
that yeah i'm just like oh like
especially in a death moment where
someone starts to say something that you
know they won't ever get to experience
or they won't it won't come true for
them like that's a device that works
very well on me yeah it's really
harrowing and desperate love it
good stuff all around man i think the
way they really i like the nighttime
rain action sequence probably the most
and that's great this military operation
man i don't blame them for what they got
to do
i don't either if i was not
in
these kids shoes yeah if i was just like
in the quarantine zone
and i heard
like hey people and i saw i think hi son
hyo sam hyo-san um
take it from me a white guy you're
probably closer than me uh from heroes
on from people over there i'm like oh
they're breaking through and that's
where this all started and you know it's
pretty bad like they're not really
finding any people alive yeah and like
the military's thinking of bombing and
i'd be like [ __ ] vomit
you're gonna contain this thing man
whatever it costs i want to live think
of how many lives
save
the rest of korea and the world i don't
think i'd be a good person about the
whole thing
of course i'd like to fantasize and be
like no go in there save people okay
craig you're going to come with us oh
[ __ ] no no no i'm not going to what are
you crazy i got my life in line use my
resources for that
yeah for sure yeah
so i i get the um the idea it's like the
way they presented they br sometimes the
people who are so tactical about it come
across so cold that the show kind of
sometimes depending on the character
they're focusing on i would not say like
the the main military general guy
doesn't seem like a bad person to me but
the there's like sort of the political
figures or i'm like you seem like a
total cold-hearted [ __ ] about it oh
the head of the party guy coming in the
beginning of the episode to be like here
i'll protect your career to the end man
just you guys got to resign
yeah yeah so
all that being said you know it's again
a battle of perspectives and that's
greenhouse guy it's just something else
i'm just like what the hell what is this
like insane werewolf dog sniffing
ability you come from like how far away
is this yeah there's this trail you
picked up on it feels like his fault or
even scent of their travel is that what
was going on yeah and i mean namra has
that too but it seems like we nom is
like smelling them from like miles away
well i think the show plays it like he
smelled them from miles away but i think
he was just picking up on a trail of
where they were running that probably or
or maybe even the sound too like he's
trying
the sound i mean you know but vibrations
are creating a sentence
but yeah no i feel like there was a
moment there where
it
kind of got overlapped to me where it's
like he's sniffing around but you also
hear like the banging on the door and
stuff so yeah i couldn't tell if he was
just trying to sniff them out or not or
who knows maybe the wind patterns you
know or blowing down wind and if
everything smells dead and then only a
few people smell alive maybe there's
that but this is the highest death count
of the characters we've actually hung
out with in a while at least i don't
know what the actual tally is but i
think in a while because we got like
at least three yeah homeboy sacrificed
himself at the top and then uh jun young
at the end
and then homegirl on the on the way he
sacrificed himself the guy who they were
wheeling around
whining whose only character beat was to
wine until that one moment where he
actually you know bought them some time
and did something heroic
yeah but still but i liked how the
revelation came out of our smoker girl
yeah how in that moment she was you know
she always been such a [ __ ] to him
in that final moment
of just
he was like i don't care no we're gonna
and she was fighting to save him no
matter what yeah
some really great character beats this
episode and like
there's a lot of yeah it's like we lost
more people in the immediate you know
focus than we have in a few episodes and
we also got to counterbalance that some
nice like heartfelt moments like i
really liked uh
daisu is that his name the guy like him
confessing his uh his uh infatuation
to uh cool archer girl
and all that she's the mvp no i'm runner
i could walk out of this
dude if they if them two teamed up
they're unstoppable just back to back
well i think non-restaurant as powerful
as him because she hasn't fed
that makes a lot of sense yeah or she's
feeding whenever he can
on anything and everything
it's like she knows she's a zombie yeah
she's fully aware she's just trying to
be as logical and rational as she can
despite that well i like these sequences
when they get like crafty and like
really
get creative together to
solve their way out of a situation yeah
and they gotta build something or they
gotta yeah like that's that's been a
nice thing it's like oh these kids are
either already capable or they're good
at at least looking at their environment
and and coming up with something you
know which is funny enough i i feel like
i'm not used to seeing as much and
granted not as many zombie things that
you see regularly are this ensemble
driven so like the whole point is there
is like a team that you can rely upon
but it's been really nice to have it
feel like we just got these found
objects you know we don't have like
weapons galore to uh to rely upon so
yeah it's just got to be wit and and two
things like that like i like they put
you in their shoes like when they're all
voting and deciding on how to build the
thing i'm like yeah
i don't really know what would be the
best way i guess building up high seems
smarter than building low but who's to
say yeah
yeah
it's good it's well well-worn i think it
would be stupid to have built it low
because if they all got on top
it would be really difficult to move it
like they could barely move it
when they're standing yeah it's it would
be
they wouldn't be able to move it at all
barricaded better
yeah but they would definitely be able
to they wouldn't be able to push that
[ __ ] no yeah probably any any covering
they put on top would probably be
crushed under the weight of so many just
bodies trying to get in yeah
i think they ultimately did the right
thing
um so my predictions are jung-sun's
gonna die
i think he i think this show keeps
hinting that he's gonna die okay
i think
i think that firefighter guy dad is
still gonna die okay
all the men in her life are going to die
and then anjo is going to be the the
remainder
and uh
that's all i got
but the other ones i hate
the other ones i'm like ah we'll see
yeah yeah in terms of major debts i'm
feeling like those two definitely are
gonna die um jury's out still for me on
chung-sun but i think i think the dad is
going to ultimately make some kind of
sacrifice or yeah be taken it's going to
be reward enough that they get reunited
at all
there's going to be a
a thing that like
it's a good thing he showed up so she
could live yes and so that she could at
least have that one last
bit that so many of them don't get which
is you know okay i got to see my
parent figure again so i don't feel
quite so alone when i have to go out on
my own true be without them
we'll see how it all unfolds just two
more episodes left
guys leave your thoughts down below hit
that like button last but not least
daniel gallacher my friend if the [ __ ]
ever hit the fan you would be in a prime
position dude what
because you're scottish and if anybody
knows the best fighters in the world
it's the scots all right you would be
taking down zombies left and right bare
knuckle boxing them with your abs
rippling pecs bulging you're not even
getting bit like zombies just hanging
off your arm by the teeth but you are
just sitting there
the teeth break off
on your bulging muscles and then when
you finally reach civilization
everyone's gonna be like what is this
guy we have to synthesize a steroid out
of his blood and then from there you'll
be a patient zero of a whole other
variety turning mankind into super
beings so daniel
live through the apocalypse my friend i
have no doubt that you will and we'll
catch you next month hope your 2022 is
going good
that wasn't bad wasn't bad right i
already won the pharmacy wrap good job
thanks man
i did my best to not do that
[Music]
you